Now you're going to write the code to make
sure that the user's logged in, if they
try to use the saveProfile function. Look for
the places marked TODO 2 in the saveProfile
method in the Conference API class. You're going to
want to go ahead and add final User
user as the first argument to saveProfile. The
user argument has to be the first argument and
the argument that defines the data structure of the
input fields is the second argument and in our case,
that's profile form. Then go ahead and add the
check to make sure that the user is logged in.
If the user is null, throw an UnauthorizedException exception.
You'll also want to get the userid. And the users
email out of the user object that gets passed
in. And then use the user id and email to
set the appropriate fields. Test your app by
using the API's Explorer on local host. You should
find, that when you try to use the saveProfile
method. You must be logged in and you can
use that simulation button in the top right
of the API's Explorer to simulate logging in. When
you've made your code changes and verified they work
on local host, go ahead and deploy to appspot.
Then go ahead and enter your APP Id here, so that Udacity can test your app